not everyone was here so let's just very
quickly rehearse this whole idea of
cryptography and then connect it back to
maths a little bit because we just kind
of jumped in without talking about it
okay so we'll look at this word
and we recall that there's an adjective
that we use that comes from the same
word right what was the adjective
cryptid right which means which means
mysterious okay so the idea of something
being unclear not sure what it means
okay and so the verbs that go along with
that right uh well to make something
cryptic is to encrypt it right so the
process of doing that is encryption
the opposite of encryption or to encrypt
something is to do it okay and these
these pairs of words are very closely
related to
the word cipher so you can insight for
something which is the same as
encryption
or you can decipher it
same idea okay
so then we had a look at a siphon we had
to look at a very famous one what was it
it was the caesar sci-fi right the
caesar sci-fi and it used
two
simple kinds of maps right how did the
caesar cipher work what was the first
thing that you did
you took all letters you made them as
numbers and then what did you do to
those numbers
you shifted them you just add something
right so you add
you take some constant you add it to all
of them and then we did the second thing
to make sure you got a letter at the
other end what was the second thing
was the second field of maths that we
used
started with an m
modularity right
so the idea of
taking a remainder okay so you add
things on you add things on but then you
would
divide by 26 and find the remainder so
that you got a letter okay but then we
saw the series i had this critical
critical weakness right not only were
there you know one letter words of which
there are not many okay what was the
main weakness that we found
okay so
we did see that spaces are a problem but
more of a problem the spaces were that
in normal english and in other languages
it's the same just for in a different
distribution
um the main weakness
right
is the frequency of letters right letter
frequency because in normal english and
you can even see it on the words that
are on the board right now okay
in normal english some letters are far
more common than others yes
yeah main weakness okay so does that
make sense
okay
so this is the main weakness right now
what i'm going to yeah question i mean
do you remember yesterday's lesson can
someone help them out why why is letter
frequency why is that a weakness why is
that a problem
yeah um
good fantastic so let me repeat that
because that's exactly right you can
even have a look on the board right for
instance far and away the most common
letter on the on the board is e you're
there there there there there there
there there
uh there
there there there and there again and
there again
in almost every word and some words you
double up right
so if i were to take this whole board
and you apply the caesar cipher to it
right here's the problem all the e's
will become some other letter but it'll
be the same letter every time so it
might turn into a t and then you can
have t's everywhere and you can make an
educated guess and you can crack the
cipher you can break it okay
so we have two solutions to this problem
okay so this is where we're now breaking
into newer ground right we looked at
this yesterday
two solutions to this main weakness
okay
um i'll tell you the first one first
it's more detailed and we're going to
spend more time on it next week
the first technique the first solution
is to see this see this
adding
division and remainders they're really
easy the maths of these is very simple
okay which is part of why it's so easy
to break so one of the solutions is to
use more complicated maths right if you
do like weird functions like
exponentials and trig functions or bring
in complex numbers or something crazy
like that
you can use more complicated maths than
this and so what you'll end up with is
more complex and harder to break okay so
there's the first solution we're going
to look a bit at an example of that or a
few examples of that next week
but there's a simpler way it's a much
simpler way and it's what we're going to
focus on today right
the problem with this is that because
you're adding the same number to every
letter that's why all the e's will turn
into all the t's or all the whatever
okay
so what if we could fix that
what if we could not shift
by a constant each time right so it's
still using the idea of addition and
still using the same idea of modularity
and remainders and division okay so it
retains the easy maths which is a good
thing because you're going to be
encoding all these long messages it's
not easy for a computer to do
we're still using the same mass but
we're going to make it and i'm going to
show you a method that if it's used
properly is
unbreakable like literally unbreakable
it's not an exaggeration it is there's a
mathematical proof for why this new
method i'm about to show you
is invulnerable it cannot be broken
and the method is called a one-time pad
okay and what is a one-time pad um i
made one so i could show you in fact as
we very important in a second um i made
two see what
here is a one-time pad can you all see
it i tried to make sure the numbers were
big enough so that you could vaguely see
what's going on here okay so here's a
one-time pad and i have two of them
exact copies okay so what i'm going to
do is i've got one and i'm going to hand
the other one to brendan okay so now he
and i have copies identical of the same
one-time pattern
now you can read the numbers across the
top right you've got 8 19 13 4 23 and so
on okay so what i'm gonna do is the way
a one-time pad works is
the same principle
as
this
caesar cipher which is shifting letters
along okay so the same principle i'm
still
shifting
letters
okay but this time instead of adding the
same number same number same number to
all of the characters
i'm going to add different numbers every
single time okay so suppose i have a
five letter word okay let's actually try
and do this um we'll see if we can help
each other out here um if i wanted to
send a five letter word like say
it's a five better word guys
happy
that's a good example actually and
you'll see why in a second right if i
wanted to send the word happy the first
thing i do is i've got to convert them
all to numbers okay so help me out i
happen to know that that's 8 and that's
one what would the letter p be
a b c d
surely we wrote this down didn't go back
to yesterday's work didn't we
16 okay so this will be 16 this will
also be 16
and y would be 25 because it's the
second last letter okay
so then what i will do is i'll say okay
i've got my one-time pad right and for
the first letter i'm going to add
the first number
eight right so this is going to become
plus 8 which is 16
okay
then i move over to the next one i've
got 19 there so i should add 19 to this
okay so it'll become 20.
uh what am i going to add to this 13.
so this is going to become okay now we
need our modular arithmetic don't we
right so this will become 29
but that should really be three
shouldn't
okay mod 26 because 29 is not really
equal to three it's only equal to three
when you take one two six
um okay now the next letter is still a
16 but i've moved over to the next one i
moved over to a four now so i'm going to
add four so that'll be 20
and then the last one 23 that's a big
one
so that's going to be
48
which is the same as 22
mod 26
is that okay
right
so what am i actually going to transit
what do these letters correspond to well
just by coincidence we've got 16 here so
i know that's going to be a new color
that's going to be a p
okay what's 20
p
t
wait hold on t yes
um three that'll be a c
um i'm going to say the t again and then
22 to uv v
okay so this is what i'm going to send
now
p t c t v okay now can you see why
despite its simplicity
why this is so superior and why it's
unbreakable
you see what's going on look at this
see this t and this t
they don't even represent the same
letter in the original right
this t came from an a
and this t came from a p right and in
exactly the same way i had a repeat
letter here
but they didn't become repeat letters
later on so now if you come back to this
and i look at all of my e's which comes
so many times almost certainly every one
of these e's will become after it's in
siphon right will become a different
letter so you can't do this letter
frequency thing it's all going to be
completely jumbled up
so that's how i encode okay and what i
would do is we could say as the name
suggests one time pad right i never want
to use this pad again right i'm gonna
say oh look i've i've used these five
already okay if i wanted to continue the
message i would keep going when i get to
the end of this page
i tear it off i destroy it and i never
see it again and then i keep going okay
okay so
why is this better than the caesar
cipher
okay
no obvious patterns will emerge unlike
here okay so now brendon receives my
message
okay
and because he's in possession of the
exact same one-time pad that i have he
can go through and he can start with the
first letter and he can well i add him
right so what should he do
he should subtract okay so he's going to
convert these all into numbers so he'll
get this
then he's going to subtract and again
he'll have to do mod 26 right
so for instance you know this three
this three this is a tricky one because
you're like oh he will subtract the
third number which is 13. right so 3
minus 13 is negative 10
ah but when you do mod 26 that's going
to be the same as 16 right
because these are 26 letters apart can
you see that so they're really the same
letter okay and he will get back for p
then i started
okay
so this is a way to securely transmit
things between brandon and i okay and
it's unbreakable here's the point like
even if you intercept this message right
if you don't have the same one-time pad
that i have and brendan has you have no
chance no chance okay
so sounds pretty good doesn't it right